هنا نقف
عبر بوتوماك من
مقبرة أرلينغتون حيث يستريح الأبطال
الذين قدموا آخر قدر كامل من
التفاني في سلام أبدي
وهنا نقف بعد أيام فقط من ظن
الغوغاء المشاغبين
أنهم يستطيعون استخدام العنف
لإسكات إرادة الناس
لوقف عمل  ديمقراطيتنا
لإخراجنا من هذه الأرض المقدسة
، لم يحدث ذلك ولن يحدث أبدًا
ليس اليوم وليس غدًا ولا أبدًا
ولا
أبدًا لجميع أولئك الذين دعموا حملتنا ،
إنني أشعر بالتواضع من الإيمان الذي وضعته
فينا لجميع أولئك الذين فعلوا ذلك.  لا تدعمنا ،
دعني أقول هذا
اسمعني بينما نمضي قدمًا ، اتخذ
مقياسًا مني وقلبي
، وإذا كنت لا تزال غير موافق ،
فليكن هذا
هو حق أمريكا في الاختلاف سلميًا ،
فربما تكون قضبان الحراسة في جمهوريتنا هي
هذه الأمة.
أعظم قوة حتى الآن تسمعني بوضوح أن
هذه الاتفاقية يجب ألا تؤدي إلى هذا
الاتحاد وأنا أتعهد لك بذلك سأكون
رئيسًا
لجميع الأمريكيين جميع الأمريكيين
[تصفيق] وأعدك بأنني
سأقاتل مثل  متحمسون
لمن لم يدعموني
وكذلك لمن
فعلكم [تصفيق]